how old are you started YouTube then
1700 [ __ ] okay I would see I would do
still do dumb [ __ ] up until 20 yeah I
started my youtube at 19 right holy crap
some of the stuff that I said I I look
back now and you know you look back and
you know the motives as well to why you
said the dumb [ __ ] oh yeah yeah oh never
have now right of course like you you're
like I want to be seen in this way so
I'm gonna say opinion that isn't really
mine but I know people will view me if I
like I look back in my my first videos
and I [ __ ] cringe man I could not
finish oh my god I'm so [ __ ] glad
that the way the internet was was like
the perfect time I think for when I was
growing up because like yeah there is
still the kind of thing of you could say
whatever the [ __ ] you wanted if you got
away with it right like I'm sure I said
some [ __ ] horrible stuff on runescape
and Xbox Live people right off like you
know now I mean kind of stuff gets hold
against you yeah yeah I'm glad that I
had that room to grow room to know that
school days was garbage you know without
having to make a video about it I mean
my school days is a masterpiece guys
actually make a video what you did oh
we're watching that five minutes I kind
of watch it is so cringy but it's like
me and like a [ __ ] leg during the era
where like known as the guy as to where
the real fast yeah I had like I had a
like a chopper hat that was like the
huge like chopper hat and I was also
wearing this like rainbow beanie with
like a scarf attached to and [ __ ]
I looked close to save the LEAs I don't
know why anyone was like oh yeah this
guy's looks good but like yeah like on
ironically I was like you know what now
that I'd like mulling it over I think
school days is aiming is really freaking
good and it's a channel right now like
I'll keep that [ __ ] up because it is
getting a DREV he's gonna I can't I like
to keep it up to like kind of remind my
audience that like you know I used to be
like this but now obviously I've changed
my view on school days and a lot of
shows because I've as you said I've had
the room to grow now and the room so
watch yeah I think it's funny to look
back here old videos where your cringe
is [ __ ] yeah I used to be like this is
what I'm like now you know yeah I mean
you can see clear improvement I like I
like seeing the growth you know yeah
yeah that feels good it feels it hurts
to watch some of your older videos I
actually watched it and I'm like I sound
so much more British yeah so [ __ ]
mind
I didn't realize such a northern accent
yeah start of YouTube well when I made
you you have like the thickest Walsh
accent yeah kind of been like destroyed
yeah which is nice you know I mean ice
to be clearly but I think that's to
coincide with all like YouTube growth I
think you have that as well especially
in your tastes and anime when you're a
teenager and what you like and you know
you can allowed yourselves or trash
taste for a reason yeah
Joey's Joey's really pulling his weight
on that just as easily
this episode has been on [ __ ] poor
bring the trashy and all right if Saul's
gonna do is gonna be me